[Music]
well here we go guys we're five hours
into our road trip here we're in Alabama
and Tommy is taking advantage of the
pitstop to load up his cargo pants with
as many slim jims as possible and
Becca's giving Jacob a good feeding and
Nathan who will never admit it actually
pooped himself and we finally got him
wrestled to the ground and changed the
smite protest so they have gleaned
diaper there bud
yeah I feels good doesn't it just
another wonderful pit stop on our eight
hour road trip from Tennessee to
Mississippi well guys we just spent
eight hours in the car your bottom sore
your back hurts we've been in the car a
long time you guys all been really good
[Music]
[Applause]
it looks like someone's been smoking
weed in the elevator we got a nice
little two-room suite for the family got
a little kitchenette over here lovely
view of the pool going on the kids are
gonna love that and Jacobs got himself a
jumping space is that right Jacob and
nice little master suite we got another
room just like this over there for the
kids so it's about eight o'clock nine
o'clock so you go ahead and put the kids
to bed and tomorrow we're gonna go see
what we can do about having some funding
maybe catching some fish too ah it feels
good to get some sleep huh and it's a
beautiful day outside and we are excited
to go explore Mississippi how are you
guys you want to explore Mississippi
yeah yeah we've never been in
Mississippi before so this is kind of
cool yeah let's go get some breakfast
anything you like that
looking good baby take you what we're
gonna do with this lovely Memorial Day
but any good plans well this is where
everyone's telling me to go fish for
drum
I'm gonna check this out and see what
people have to say about this my guy he
was giving me the hookups he says that
the drummer down in the calmer water
yeah I like a boss man oh look at this
there you go man you got a fish fry
coming here well guys this is Lafleur
Bluffs State Park here in Jackson
Mississippi and I'm gonna check this
place out and see what the fishin
situation is cuz I really want to catch
a big Buffalo I talked to these guys
back here not much is going on but I'm
seeing lots of guard jumpin I be okay
with some gar that'd be cool so so my
wife was all freaking out like hey we're
Mississippi now there might be there
might be alligators but now I'm sure
there's no alligator we just fine
there's a freakin alligator right there
you see him moving right there just
swimming along he looks like he's about
5 feet long yeah probably but don't
worry
Nathan's a lot shorter and smaller he'll
probably Nathan first he just
disappeared well he might be he might be
coming to hunt you down so that's
hanging out in the playground so Becky
you know how I said there's no
alligators here five footer over there
I'm gonna pull out see what happened not
super optimistic I think the spillway it
looks better but hey I got the time and
the opportunity let's try it out you
found a dinosaur tooth or a dinosaur
claw all those your fossils that's a
dead softshell turtle right there I'm
gonna set up one rig for Buffalo and use
a method lead and a hair rig and all
that good stuff
and I'm gonna set up another rig for
drum and I'm gonna use a high-low rig
I'm gonna do my basic punko pack bait
here
[Music]
all right there we go try to met the
lead packed with some panco jello and
sweet corn we're see we can't catch a
buffalo as a t-rex - you're actually
found a pretty legit Stegosaurus fossil
there didn't you that does look like an
alligator egg or something does that or
a turtle egg
we have driven 15 hours to play with the
kids at a playset you know what we're
having a great day well I got a few hits
and a few beeps on the vital arms but
not much is going on that it's hot it's
in the middle of the day I'm not
terribly surprised you know right there
we run up in the air put it up in the
air you got it
tiny little channel catfish very very
first Mississippi fish there we go
would you rather stay here and fish or
go get some lunch and ice cream soda
line for about an hour and a half
caught one little tiny channel catfish
got some bites but it's just been fun
relaxing day the kids got to play on the
play set but we are gonna go grab some
barbecue something cold to drink and we
are going to relax a little bit
[Music]
this is what life's all about it's about
eating ribs and barbeque on a fold-out
bed with your family in front of the TV
yeah that's the good stuff right there
me and Nathan are gonna go try out that
spillway and see if we can't catch some
drum tonight we kind of do some
reconnaissance
you ready to go fishing buddy well we're
gonna go to Academy get some fishing
gear then we're gonna hit the bank my
first time going to Academy the whole
mix in here there's some worms no will
you hold these buddy
don't let the worms get out hi let's go
fishing we're gonna see if we can't
catch some drama Buffalo here it goes
well tonight we're gonna come back here
and film some more maybe tomorrow or the
next day so we'll see how it goes
you got those worms grab it grab it
you have a date hello pull it up hi reel
them in a little baby Channel cat there
we go hi five months yeah
[Music]
oh he is a fighter
you've got to fish you kind of drum
that's a drum no that's it that's a drum
and that's a table cat and look at that
nathan is your drum there we go
well high-five Nate you got to fish in
one go
well me Nathan had a good time catching
some little baby catfish and had our
first drum Nathan got one and I got one
so congratulations Nathan it's another
beautiful day and we're do a little
exploring hang out together family maybe
just picnicking and of course there will
be fishing so so let's let's go see what
there is to be had
hey guys I'm Addie low State Park here
just some goldfish here must be the
goldfish big fatties
yeah those will catch some flat head the
blue in the water to keep the algae down
yeah well guys I'm here at DLO State
Park and I picked up some minnows and
some goldfish and it's a little bit of
tackle and the people here are just
super friendly they gave me some tips on
where to go fishing and swimming hey
buddies you guys want to go fish and
swim yeah well let's go check it out
we're gonna go drive down the road a
little bit okay let's check out this
creek man this is gorgeous
little kid pool well guys we're head
this lovely little Creek and we are
grossly unprepared we only have one of
the boys life vests we don't have swim
trunks I'm wearing jeans and boots yeah
and I've got a 10-foot carp rod but you
know we're just gonna make it work we're
just going to have a good time and see
what happens maybe we'll pull out some
fish we got to find a nice shady spot
where Becca can put her feet in the
water
Jacobs gonna hang out with Mama
[Music]
Nathan's on the timeout rocker disobeyin
mommies oh there we go
[Music]
[Music]
well guys got about three hits saw one
of them but this look really tiny little
guys 6 inches 8 inches long so so my
gear my baits a bit too big I think
that's real fun real beautiful
[Music]
how are you guys doing do you guys
having a good time
oh that it's a pretty spot isn't it
oh hey if you're watching that I
appreciate it
thank you very much new dig it was very
very poopy but we forgot wipes so we had
to do things we're not not proud of but
we got it cleaned anyway so let's go
home and get some food and take it easy
well we dropped off mom and Tommy and
Jacob and me and Nate are gonna go fish
the spillway again we're gonna see if we
can't catch ourselves a big Buffalo
maybe a decent catfish this time
ready let's do it all right Nate come on
keep going buddy did you fill your boot
up full of sand
[Music]
here we go another channel catfish on my
cart babe
sittin here with the camping chair in
vile arms maybe lazy man fishing but
that is exactly what I need today oh I'm
exhausted sweat sweat through this shirt
like nobody's business - that is just
crazy look at all those fish look at
this all of a sudden the river just came
alive there's fish everywhere just
jumping I have no idea what they are
nathan has completely filled his boot
full of sand I mean this thing is solid
sand well guys we had an absolute blast
fishing here at this spillway didn't we
did we Nathan yeah we had a good time
tell lots of little fish nothing fancy
but had a fun and it was a great time
with with the boy
why don't you gonna see mom in it Tommy
let's go let's go home
well guys we're back we're filthy and we
need to freeze those goldfish
so we're improvising chicken nugget
package full of goldfish it's 9:10 p.m.
but I promised the boys that take them
swimming so here we are all right guys
you ready for a late night swim gonna
lizard look at the lizard
see look at the lizard all right guys
let's have some fun yeah finally Batman
okay
[Music]
[Music]
so you guys gonna be excited to do this
wall mount my truck my class tomorrow
alright guys so let's go back to the
hotel let's go see mommy and Gigi
well guys here I am in downtown Jackson
and I'm gonna be attending a seminar
here I'm a criminal defense attorney and
that's why I'm here in Mississippi
actually is 2:10 this little training
session conference singer majiggy so had
to change into my nice clothes do this
for a couple days while the kids have
fun
I just found out they cancelled the
seminar on me literally walk in there oh
yeah I've been canceled like I just
drove from Virginia to be here Hey oh
you didn't get the email I'm not gonna
think too deeply about what a pain in
the butt that is and just have fun and
be glad that you get a couple more days
to fish with my kids we need to go do
something now we have some good friends
that we haven't seen in years who live
in Baton Rouge Louisiana which is like
what two and a half three hours south of
this so we just got off the phone and
they say they've got a bed available for
us and they live on a lake right yeah so
that sounds like we need to go visit
some friends in Baton Rouge
let's go we'll just be even farther for
Virginia that's gonna be if you'd like
to see more great outdoor boys videos
including all the videos from this
southern road trip check out the link in
the description and don't forget to
click subscribe we put out new videos
every week and join us every Saturday
morning for a new adventure from the
outdoor boys thanks for watching